Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Perché le piante ci hanno inventato?
Perché ci hanno inventato?
Ci hanno inventato perché hanno creato
l'atmosfera dove noi viviamo.
Hanno creato l'atmosfera
che noi respiriamo:
senza le piante,
noi non potremmo respirare.
Il cibo:
il cibo che noi mangiamo
deriva direttamente
o indirettamente, dalle piante.
Senza le piante,
noi non potremmo mangiare.
Oserei dire che non potremmo
neanche tanto bere, ecco.
Materiale da costruzione:
da che mondo è mondo, le piante
ci accompagnano volontariamente -
e anche meno volontariamente -
nella costruzione delle nostre case,
delle nostre suppellettili,
dei nostri mobili, dei nostri arredi.
Nella mobilità, fino all'Ottocento:
carri, carretti, diligenze, calessi.
Senza quelli, non ci si muoveva.
La navigazione:
senza quel materiale da costruzione,
le barche e le navi, insomma -
senza le tre caravelle,
probabilmente le Americhe
sarebbero ancora molto lontane.
L'energia!
L'energia che noi usiamo
deriva quasi principalmente dalle piante:
legname, carbone, petrolio, gas.
Senza questi elementi, probabilmente,
la nostra raffinata tecnologia
non si muoverebbe -
e noi, molto probabilmente,
rimarremmo anche al freddo.
Il 98% dei principi attivi
della nostra medicina
vengono estratti dalle piante,
e anche della nostra cosmetica.
Quindi, senza le piante
noi non potremmo curarci,
e non potremmo neanche abbellirci.
Io no, perché vabbé, ho ben altre cose.
(Risate)
Il suolo:
la terra che noi calpestiamo
non è che c'è sempre stata!
No, è frutto del lavoro
di milioni e milioni di anni
delle piante, insieme a dei microrganismi.
Senza questo connubio, senza le piante,
noi probabilmente cammineremmo
ancora sulle rocce.
La bellezza: nella forma,
nei colori, fiori, frutti,
le piante ci hanno donato grande bellezza.
Quindi noi non possiamo
fare a meno delle piante,
siamo dipendenti dalle piante.
Anzi, oserei dire che noi siamo
i veri parassiti delle piante:
anche se noi siamo parenti delle piante,
siamo cugini stretti,
in noi c'è qualcosa delle piante.
Se mi guardo in giro,
quel signore lì assomiglia
a un rododendro, sicuro: si vede!
La signora che ho visto
entrare, flessuosa,
sembrava una donna bellissima,
un bellissimo pioppo;
C'è lì un signore pelato
che sembra un cavolo cappuccio.
(Risate)
Insomma, in noi c'è qualcosa delle piante:
non possiamo farne a meno.
Tra l'altro, anche culturalmente
le piante ci hanno plasmato.
Ma pensate a Tarzan!
Tarzan vive nella giungla,
si sposta con le liane.
Senza le liane, cosa fa?
Si attacca alle tende di casa? No.
Ma pensate al mito,
al mito svizzero Guglielmo Tell
che mette una mela sulla testa del figlio
e poi la centra con una freccia.
Senza la mela, cosa gli metteva?
Una tavoletta di cioccolato?
No, perché deriva anche il cioccolato,
dalle piante. Capite?
O anche il nostro Robin Hood,
che scaglia frecce micidiali di legno.
Senza legno con che cosa le faceva,
con le stecche degli ombrelli?
Ma pensate a Noè, al Diluvio Universale.
Noè mi costruisce l'Arca.
E con che cosa la costruisce, l'arca?
Con le pelli di capra gonfiate?
No, la costruisce
sacrificando una foresta -
che poi ci mette su gli animali
ma non le piante, tra l'altro.
Però, quando capisce
che le acque si ritirano
manda la colomba, la colomba torna
e cos'ha nel becco, una marmotta?
No: ha un rametto di ulivo,
segno che ancora una volta
le piante hanno rigenerato il mondo.
Ma pensate alla scienza.
Newton sta lì, bello seduto sotto un melo.
Cade una mela, colpo di genio,
capisce che esiste la gravità
e ne costruisce una formula.
Se gli fosse caduto in testa una tegola,
ti saluto a Newton e ti saluto gravità.
Ma pensate anche alle fave -
eh, alle fave, alle favole.
Questo è un lapsus: fave -
(Applausi)
Pensate, dicevo, alle favole:
la favola per eccellenza, Pinocchio.
Pinocchio è scolpito
in un blocco di legno.
Immaginatevi Pinocchio col didò.
(Risate)
Arriva la fatina con la bacchetta magica -
di legno, tra l'altro -
vede il didò e non le viene neanche,
da trasformarlo in uomo.
Anzi, capite?
Pinocchio legno diventa uomo: anche qui
c'è una sottigliezza incredibile.
Pensate anche i libri, signori:
senza le piante non ci sarebbero i libri.
Immaginatevi Mosè,
Mosè con 'ste due tavole
che va sul Monte Sinai.
Sta su 40 giorni.
Le Scritture ci dicono:
sì, è stato su 40 giorni
perché ha dovuto meditare,
collegarsi con Dio -
No, ha dovuto scolpire dieci leggi,
ci ha messo una vita!
Immaginatevi Umberto Eco
che scolpisce "Il nome della rosa".
Quanto tempo ci avrebbe messo?
Ma soprattutto,
noi che librerie dovremmo avere
per sostenere quel volume lì?
Capite? Tutto deriva -
Non solo, non so: la musica!
La musica senza le piante non esisterebbe.
Non solo per la scrittura,
ma anche per gli strumenti:
tre quarti degli strumenti sono di legno.
Noi dovremmo sempre andare
a sentire - (suono di fiati)
Immaginatevi, non ci sarebbero i mariachi.
L'allegria dei mariachi!
Non ci sarebbero gli Inti-Illimani:
per il flauto a pan che usano,
le canne dell'acqua di piombo?
No!
Capie? Tutto deriva da lì.
Ma pensate, pensate, non so.
Ecco: Battisti, che canta
"Fiori rosa, fiori di pesco".
Con che cosa lo sostituisci?
Oppure, che ne sai tu
di un campo di grano?
Cosa dici?
Che ne sai di un calorifero di ghisa?
Non suona bene, no? Non mi suona bene.
(Applausi)
Una betulla, lei:
hai visto come si è mossa?
(Risate)
Pensate poi allo sport
più bello del mondo, il calcio.
Senza quel bel tappeto erboso,
Cristiano Ronaldo dove li fa
i dribbling, sul cemento?
Pensate Cuadrado, che si butta giù
20 volte a partita.
Si sbuccerebbe tutto: dopo due giorni
non gioca più, Cuadrado.
Capite?
Tutto, veramente tutto
deriva dalle piante.
Poi una cosa - il cinema.
Signori, una delle cose
più belle: il cinema.
Le prime pellicole
erano fatte con la cellulosa.
Senza il cinema, non ci sarebbe
"Tre uomini e una gamba", ragazzi.
(Applausi)
Poi, un posto mitico: senza le piante,
non ci sarebbe quel posto mitico
dove ormai tutti si va in pellegrinaggio,
le coppie, soprattutto, e le famiglie,
il sabato e la domenica e in tutta Europa.
Capite? non ci sarebbe l'Ikea!
Vi rendete conto del disastro?
Per cui dobbiamo prenderci cura
degli alberi, assolutamente.
Ah, ecco poi una cosa importantissima:
non ci sarebbe una delle città
più belle al mondo - dopo Mantova:
(Risate)
non ci sarebbe Venezia.
Forse non lo sapete,
ma le fondamenta di Venezia
sono state costruite
con centinaia di migliaia
di pali di quercia e rovere.
Il sacrificio di due foreste
fa sì che Venezia stia in piedi.
Per cui, dobbiamo veramente
prenderci cura degli alberi,
anche perché spesso io, di notte,
sogno di essere un albero.
Ciao a tutti.
(Applausi)